Syria and its closest allies are
speaking out against the US missile
attack Holly Williams is in Istanbul
Turkey with a global reaction Holly good
morning good morning there are no
surprises at all in their responses from
the Syrian regime as well as its ally
and backer Russia the Syrian regime
called the strikes on Sherrod airbase an
act of blatant aggression this morning
and said it made the u.s. a partner with
Isis and other terrorist groups Russia
says the strikes violate international
law based on a quote trumped up pretext
remember both the regime and Russia have
denied that there was a chemical attack
on the town of honshou moon on Tuesday
despite all of the evidence we've seen
emerging since then American allies
including the United Kingdom Turkey
Saudi Arabia and Israel support these
strikes here in Turkey they're even
calling for more action with a no-fly
zone in northern Syria we spoke with
several Syrian rebel groups last night
very happy to see US military action
against the Syrian regime because they
hope it'll stop the regime from bombing
them Charlie